I heard something very nice but you gave
a very inspirational speech I believe it
was this is very recent beautycon at
beautycon i first of all you should tell
me I am not invited for reasons it
escaped me to beautycon no you are
invited everyone is invited to beautycon
it ok what my speech about was about
beautycon just tell us where is
beautycon it takes place in London New
York and clear but it is a big beauty
conference and I did a speech about the
beautiful you and the culture beauty is
very limiting in the way that it defines
what beauty is it's ever-changing
standards that really have been defined
by the objectifying gaze and so I told
within that story of redefining or
expanding not redefining but expanding
the culture of beauty I talked about how
the limiting definition left me at odds
with myself growing up and you talk
about the definition specifically for
women men young women growing up they
obviously they see these magazines they
see what's shown on television and in
the movies and they think that that's in
lips straight hair then it's a big but
then it's a small but then it's I mean
like you can't keep up and it's
arbitrary and so as a young girl I used
to twist myself in knots and like try
and become the person physically that I
thought I should be as opposed to Who I
am
and so I had all these ridiculous tests
of things that I would do each of things
you and you talked about at the speech
these are things you would really do as
a young as a young woman one was I
didn't like my full lips which are not
even that full and I would I taught
myself to smile so my top lip would go
away and you just curl you just got my
teeth now right I also had I would grab
my tush because I have a fuller figure
and I would grab my tush and if while
holding it this is a little x-rated but
because there's a lot back there I was
like fantastic you look absolutely
beautiful you thank
politely keeping my I don't want I don't
want to be caught like scary yeah I
don't know where so I would grab it and
I would walk and if I could still hold
onto it I thought it needed to go
because it wasn't needed which
ridiculous if you thought that if there
was anything coming over the sides of
your hands you thought that that meant
you had to lose yes wow that's a mess
yeah and but you know it's not just
something that comes from inside of me
like we have a world the wallpaper of
our lives is sort of telling us these
messages for women that yes our only
purpose is to be wanting to be desirable
and that is just not true right and you
had a hose that you had a third test
that was a shape jello in an earthquake
jello in an earthquake what's that you
would slam your foot down on the floor
and see how long the tush juggled now I
know that that is a determination that I
am doing great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
first of all beauty is something that
comes from within it's about expressing
your joy claiming legacy and your future
and all of that and so I believe that
beauty is in each of us and that we find
it within and I think our culture tells
us something different
did you ever have stuff growing up oh
god yeah I mean I when I was a kid I was
well I was really skinny for a while and
I hated being skinny I hated having red
hair I hated having freckles I hate
having the first name Koenen for a long
time when I was in bed and now you're
Conan yeah well I had no choice I had
it's like a boy named Sue you learn to
fight or you know your so yeah there was
a lot of things that I was unhappy about
and and I you know you just you add it
all up and then you realize much later
it took me a long time to grow into my
body I think it was I was in my late 40s
when it finally happened but wouldn't
you prefer to peak then than at 17 you
know it's funny but when you're at 17
you really wish you could peep right
then hi cuz there are guys I mean when I
was in the eighth grade there were guys
who had deep voices long sideburns you
know they they just look like men
they like smoked a cigarette they fought
in World War two and this is the late
sound you know this was the late 70s I
mean these guys were like you're like
hot and I was like hi I'm mister where
are they now
yeah where are they now yeah ones
president I can go to school with him
now yeah you say it in the eyes yeah
you